he specific applications oh brother
especially the idea of economics and and
they were very pleased okay well thanks
for showing up I know that if it was me
I wouldn't have come on elastic after
four intense very intense days wonderful
days of great talks this is going to be
light so let me just introduce the area
for those of you that are not that
familiar with an example so when we
teach algorithms we learn about maximum
weighted matching as an example of a
problem we want to solve so here the
problem is your input is awaited
bipartite graph and your goal is to find
a matching that maximizes the sum of the
edge weights so in this particular graph
the orange edges have a weight of 8 and
that's the maximum matching so now let's
consider an application of this problem
for example you have a search engine
that has ad slots for sale so the nodes
on the right hand side represent the ad
slots the nodes on the left hand side
represent the advertisers and the
numbers on the edges represent how much
that advertiser is willing to pay to
have their ads shown in that slot and
you can imagine that the search engine
wants to make as much money as possible
so they would like to compute a maximum
weight matching but there's a
fundamental problem here because where
are these numbers coming from these
numbers are the private information of
those advertisers and there's no reason
those advertisers are just going to
announce those numbers and you know let
the search engine take as much money as
possible from them in particular what
they might try to do is lie in order to
get a better deal so for example in this
case this guy here might actually rather
than say
willing to pay five dollars for this
slot he might say he's willing to pay
only three dollars he would still if the
if there's a maximum matching algorithm
being run here he would still only get
only he would still get this lot but he
would have made two dollars so to speak
of course you know it's tricky for these
guys to figure out what they should tell
the search engine as for what their
values are because in order to do that
they have to speculate about what all
these other advertisers are reporting
and that's kind of a tricky problem so I
just want to point out that this is a
game here in this particular case if
Google is a search engine google is
designing the game they get to choose
the procedure by which these reports of
how much the advertisers are willing to
pay our maps to allocations and payments
and the advertisers are the people
playing the game and so the question
becomes how should Google design this
game so that when these advertisers are
playing are doing are behaving in their
own best interest Google's goals are
achieved so there are a lot of
situations where the input is a private
data of agents who are going to
selfishly promote their own best
interests and the field of mechanism
design asks how do we merge algorithm
design with incentives and so there's
many many real-world mechanism design
settings I already have discussed
sponsor of you or alluded to sponsored
search auctions and display advertising
this is one of the killer apps of course
we all know that Google makes a lot of
money and basically this is how they
make their money and I like this quote
from their chief economist how Varian
which is they said what most people
don't know is that all that money comes
in pennies at a time and that's because
they're running millions and millions
and millions of at auctions all the time
and collecting pennies from these
advertisers but those pennies are adding
up there are many many other
applications of mechanism
sign in the real world Kevin spoke about
spectrum auctions people have studied
kidney exchange and the incentives their
health care systems recommendation
systems routing on the internet resource
allocation in the cloud platform design
for a sharing economy so here I'm
thinking about things like uber and
Airbnb which are solving these massive
optimization problems that involve
incentives bitcoin is a system design
that that depends on minors doing
something to help keep track of payments
that have occurred and they have to be
incentivized appropriately and a variety
of other topics and I just one thing you
know I I don't know if this afternoon
we'll even hear about pricing in the
context of energy but these are like
real problems and I'm not sure to what
extent our research is having that much
impact on these real problems and I
think that that's that's a really
important thing for us to be thinking
about so what characterizes these
problems well there are many
participants with diverse incentives the
private information of each agent okay
they are like in my previous example the
advertisers where the agents is unknown
to the designer of the mechanism and
presumably the other agents fact they
may not even know their own information
so we always in this area we always
assume that the agent knows their own or
we usually assume that the agent knows
their own value for a particular outcome
but in fact you know that that really
may not be the case I mean I know that I
for one don't know how to value a house
and I'm considering buying and I'm sure
that a lot of us have this this problem
they have varying attitudes towards risk
they behave with varying degrees of
myopia they may be exhibiting learning
behavior of the type we learned about
earlier in the week the if you think
about the problems that are that I had
on the this the applications I had in
the previous slide these are all
very complex optimization problems and
they involve dynamic and repeated
interaction and I sort of have this in
bold because I think it's also one of
the aspects where we I sort of
understand the least and it's actually
very complicated there are results
recently including by people in this
room like Christos and Alex and others
but these are really really complicated
problems that we don't understand very
well so what am I going to do in this
talk well not much okay good news uh
maybe and I'm going to try to meander
through a few topics very briefly
touching on them no proofs no nothing
and just try to mostly connect a little
bit with some of the things that were
discussed earlier in the week just
loosely connect and hopefully just give
you a gestalt for some of the things
that have been going on in the last ten
years in this field and anyway that's a
plan and I apologize for incomplete
references and anybody I offend okay so
I want to start with applications of
profit inequalities Matt gave this
gorgeous lecture on profit inequalities
so let's see a little bit about how
they're used in in this setting so just
to remind you his the what he was
talking about you have a sequence of
prizes each of these prizes is drawn
from some known prior distribution so
you're you want you okay so sorry go on
you know all the priors and what you do
is you see this these actual values one
at a time and at the moment that you see
a value make an irrevocable decision as
to whether or not to keep that prize or
not and the moment you keep a prize the
game is over okay so what you're trying
to do is do well compared with a prophet
who gets to see all the values in
advance and would therefore have an
expected reward which is the maximum of
the values okay
so Matt described a very simple
algorithm that will guarantee you half
of that Garrett to you a competitive
ratio of two which is simply compute the
expected maximum and take the first
prize that is above half of that okay so
that's really cool there's another
version that that is often used in
mechanism design for kind of explain one
reason we might use this one which is to
choose a threshold T such that the
probability than any of these values are
above t is one half and take the first
prize that's above t that also gives you
a factor of two competitive ratio of two
and that's a very similar proof to the
one matt gave and so both of these
guarantee that the expected value of the
prize selected is half of the expected
maximum so i want to show you just an
obvious application of this in the
context of single item auctions so first
of all let's review a few little things
about a single item auction so in a
single item auction we have a bunch of
agents each of them has a private value
for the item meaning they're indifferent
between if there are values a hundred
dollars they're indifferent between
owning that item and having a hundred
dollars in their hands they're going to
the auctioneer is going to specify some
rules for how given whatever it is they
bid those are mapped to a winner in a
price and the the agents here are going
to submit bids that that hopefully will
maximize their own utility and the
definition of utility here is the value
they get for the item if they win it
minus whatever they pay okay so one of
the simplest goals you can have if
you're designing an auction is to
maximize social surplus so this is
sometimes called I'll say surplus for
short or is sometimes called social
welfare or efficiency and the goal would
be to allocate you the bitter that has
the highest value so somehow implement
the max function
okay that's that's the goal here and
there's you know the very famous
resolved Nobel prize-winning result
which the which says that the victory
second price auction which is you
allocate to the highest bidder at the
second-highest at the second highest bid
incentivizes truth-telling so it's in
each agents best interest to report
their true value no matter what anybody
else is doing so for example if we have
two agents and their values are 180 then
with the bitter at 100 will win at a
price of a tea and some of utility will
be the difference which is 20 so this is
a great great result and you know if up
there many extensions that many of you
know about but there are some problems
with this auction so for example it's
susceptible to collusion and this is
outside the model really so if for
example agent Warren was to promise
agent to to pay him fifty dollars if he
bids 10 okay then what would asian twins
utility be well he would win the item at
ten dollars in the auction he would pay
the other a bitter fifty dollars and so
his utility would end up being 40 the
second agents utility would be 50 they
would be both be better off okay so this
is not the only issue with this auction
it can be slow and inconvenient actually
Vickrey auction is what sort of is one
of the auctions one of the things that's
done on ebay essentially and you know
often those auctions there take days or
weeks to run and that's that's kind of
not that great it may require more
communication than we would like the
agents have to report their values which
they may not want to do for privacy
reasons or because those values may be
used against them in the future all the
bidders need to be present at the time
the auction is run so if we're willing
so these are problems but if we're
willing to set for approximate
optimality and we have a prior so that
is we know something in advance about
the value the distributions these agents
values are drawn from
now we can simply use the Prophet
inequality and run a posted price action
so what would we do we choose a
threshold tea set for example such that
the probabilities if there's any bitter
whose values above tea is one-half and
we would simply post a price of tea and
whoever grabs the item first gets it and
we know by the Prophet inequality result
that this guarantees we get within a
factor of two of the expected max okay
so what are some features of this
auction it's very simple to implement
the whole thing is described by one
number you just post it it's very simple
for the agents to play they don't have
to think much in fact they don't even
really even necessarily need to exactly
know their value they just need to know
whether their values above this
threshold its robust in the sense that
it doesn't matter if the bidders aren't
all there at the same time or come in
some arbitrary or even worse case order
it's resilient to collusion there's
nothing you can do now to collude and
actually one nice thing about this which
is the only reason I switched from this
verse from the version map presented to
this version is that you can see that
with this version even if you change the
distributions of the values above or
below the threshold it doesn't change
the result so it's actually robust in
that sense to to not even being you know
to allowing variety of distributions
okay so that's really cool actually is
it's a very simple example but I think
it's cool and it's kind of the beginning
of a motivation for why you know why we
love posted prices and why profit
inequalities are so awesome I'm just
going to briefly mention a beautiful
generalization of this due to Feldman
grabbin and Lucci a so they were
considering the following problem you
have an auctioneer has em items you know
and there's an bitters and each bidder
has a value for each subset of items so
you know
example she might have some value for
this pair of items but a different value
for this item by itself different value
for this item and so on okay so each of
the bidders has a value for each subset
of the items and let's assume for now
that these values are that these value
functions are sub modular so they're
sort of decreasing marginal returns to
an agent for larger subsets actually the
result of I mentioning it goes beyond
this sub modular setting but I just this
is just easy to understand easier to
understand and suppose that the goal of
the auctioneer is to allocate items to
implement the max function so the
auctioneer wants to choose which subset
of these items to allocate to player 1
which subset to player 2 which subset to
player 3 so as to maximize the values
that they get so well okay so just a
little bit about this problem so this
problem just even as an optimization
problem forget incentives forget the
fight that the values are private is
actually a hard problem there are 1
minus 1 over e approximations that are
known this again I'm talking here if you
knew all the values you didn't have to
solicit them from the bidders now if you
want to come up with a truthful
mechanism that will you know approximate
this this objective then the best known
result we have right now is basically
logarithmic in the number of items so
this is a big gap here and you know
that's the I'll discuss that a little
bit more in a moment but something
that's really neat and sort of
surprising and it's the result of a long
line of really beautiful work in price
of anarchy is that if you were to do
something really simple like take each
of the items and run a separate first
price auction on each of them that is
how each bidder submit one bid for each
item and
and whoever submits the highest bid on
the first item gets that at their bid
and the second item whoever submits a
Heisenberg gets that and so on then
magically in equilibrium you get a 1
minus 1 over e approximation to the
optimal social welfare okay so this is
really neat and actually this word
there's more general more general ways
to state these these results but what
Feldman gravida luchia did was they took
some of the ideas from those and they
combine them with some of the profit
inequality ideas and they were able to
show that there's a simple posted price
mechanism that gets a constant
approximation so just to kind of say a
few words what they do is they figure
out sort of given the priors what's the
expected value that the optimal solution
gets from each item and they post half
that expected value okay so they post a
set of prices one for each item allow
the bidders to come in and when a bitter
comes in you know they choose their
favorite bundle of given the prices
their favorite bundle so perhaps her
utility for this is her value for those
two minus those two prices and you know
then the Ave they keep coming in and
whoever wants two picks whatever they
want their favorite bundle and these
prices guarantee a constant fraction of
the optimal expected surplus okay so
very nice is this really nice result
gives a very simple simple mechanism
that you know doesn't care when the
these bidders come in what order they
come in it's just it's it's awesome okay
so as I said already this is a case
where we don't know how to design a
truthful mechanism that gets closed to
the approximation ratio that we get in
the algorithmic setting this result that
I just mentioned is part of a line of
work that tries to bridge this gap
between algorithmic computation straight
over in the computation and computation
with incentives and tries to bridge it
by introducing prior
okay so here they're able to you know
essentially get close to the optimal
using priors and I just want to say that
this the question i mentioned that's
kind of unresolved here the worst-case
version of this problem is one of the
big driving questions in the field which
is to what extent is computability with
incentive compatibility harder than
without so this is you know if you're
going to do computations and you have to
be incentive compatible you have to
incentivize the agents to report their
values truthfully that imposes quite
severe constraints and what the
mechanism could do and so question is
how does that affect what we can compute
what problems we can solve okay so a
little bit about profit maximization
here profit inequalities are also very
useful so in order for me to tell you
that I'm going to tell you a little bit
about maximizing profit or revenue in in
auctions so this assuming known priors
is completely solved in Nobel
prize-winning work by Myerson so again
sorry I should just say so the problem
is again just design an auction now
knowing that the values are coming from
these priors so that the the auctioneer
revenue is maximized okay and so just to
the simplest case here suppose there was
only one bidder I'm the seller you're
the buyer and I know your value I'm
sorry I know the distribution from which
your value comes so I could you could
imagine that there's some complicated
thing I should do but in fact it's you
can show our Morrison showed and others
showed earlier that the optional auction
is just opposed to price and what is
that price it's going to be the price at
which the price I get times the
probability you're going to buy at that
price you'll only buy at that price of
your values above the price is maximized
and it's called the monopoly price for
the distribution okay so what about in
more general setting for example if the
bidders are IID then it turns out that
the optimal auction is just the Vickrey
auction with a monopoly reserve price so
the reserve price is like an opening bid
on eBay and what that means essentially
is that nobody can win the auction
unless they're willing to pay at least
that much and what the Vickrey auction
does is it gives the item to the highest
bidder above the reserve price if there
is any and it charges that person the
maximum of the reserve price in the
second highest bid and and this is the
optimal thing you can do in this setting
in the non iid setting things are quite
a bit more complicated here's the
optimal auction you ask bidders to
report their values for each value you
compute this weird function of their
value which is called the virtual value
and notice that you know here it it has
you know all this dependence on the
distribution and what Myerson showed is
that the expected revenue of an auction
is exactly equal to the expected virtual
value of the winner so what that
suggests is that what you want to do is
allocate to the bitter with the highest
virtual value as long as that's positive
and that turns out to be the optimal
auction and then you set the prices so
that you get so that you guarantee
truthfulness meaning in this case you
know the winning bidder will pay the
smallest biddy could have made and still
won okay so I guess the important thing
to notice about this is that it's pretty
complicated you need to know that these
these virtual value functions everywhere
in eight and wait in order to implement
the auction it's also kind of weird so
for example if your first bidder had a
value drawn from exponential
distribution with parameter 1 and your
second bidder had a value drawn from a
uniform distribution with on 0 1 and
their values were 1.5 and 0.8
then when you do this transformation it
turns out that in this optimal auction
the second bidder the one with the value
of 0.8 will win and pay 0.75 okay so
kind of weird things can happen not the
bidder who's not the highest can win and
the result is that the I mean the point
of this little example is that it's
complicated unintuitive and it depends
on detailed distributional information
okay so you can ask the question is
there a simpler more practical more
robust way for willing to sacrifice
optimality so again profit inequalities
to the rescue so as we said Myerson
tells us that a revenue will be the
expected virtual value of the winning
bidder so how would we apply a profit
inequality instead of thinking of the
values as the prizes we think of the
virtual values of surprises actually
this I'm taking a max of the virtual
value with zero okay because we never
want to allocate if the virtual value is
negative so we think of these prizes in
virtual value space and we try to get
the largest one so how would we do that
we could choose a threshold so that the
probability that the max of the virtue
of values is above t is equal to
one-half okay and if we do that then
well okay this is a fixed price in
virtual value space it actually does not
correspond to a fixed price in value
space in value space what this would do
is it induces some price what is for
each bidder what is the price at which
their virtual value is equal to that
threshold okay so basically what you do
is you do this calculation which you can
do you could you just knowing the
distributions and that determines some
threshold price for each bidder and you
just sell to the first bidder that's
willing to pay his personal reserve
price and this gives the two
approximation
so admittedly this is more complicated
because now we have bitter specific
posted prices but it's still way simpler
than the optimal auction okay and it has
all these nice properties that I was
discussing earlier so this is called
oblivious posted pricing because we
don't care what order the agents show up
in if the designer is allowed to
consider the agents in the order of his
choosing then you could get better
approximations so I guess I'll briefly
tell you how this is done so the way
this is done is as follows first rather
than solve the optimal auction problem
what these guys did is they formulated
the optimal ex-ante relaxation what that
means is essentially the fractional
version of the problem suppose I just
want to allocate the item in expectation
at most once what's the optimal revenue
i could get then so what would i do i
would solve this program I just I'm
defined qi to be the probability that
agent I wins the auction I want to
allocate in the item and expectation at
most once and now things are much
simpler in that I can optimize point
wise for each agent once I know what
this Qi is so I would want to maximize
the revenue i get from age and I
assuming that I sell to him with
probability Q I ok and this is actually
a convex program so it can be solved and
if the distributions are nice and we
want to say what that means then it
turns out that the optimal solution to
this probe to this program is a posted
pricing so it would specify for each
agent a price and what would the revenue
be the price is such that the
probability that the agent accepts that
price has a value above that price is
exactly equal to Q I okay so this is the
most revenue you could get if you
willing to sell in expectation you at
most once
and you can then say well why can't I
just run this posted price auction and
get this revenue the problem is that you
know I'd be sampling for each of these
distributions you know I'd be tossing a
coin for each agent separately and
independently whether or not they're
willing to accept that price and when I
do that I might end up selling more than
one item but maybe that more than one of
them is above the price and that's not
feasible for me in the real setting okay
so if I since so since I need to be
feasible I can but I can choose the
order in which I approach each of the
agents perhaps the right thing to do I
mean the natural thing to do is order my
attempts to serve by decreasing price so
first try the agent for which my price
is high as then try the agent which my
advice is second highest and so on and
if I do that then my revenue will be
just the sum over the agents the
probability that agents willing to
accept this price times the probability
that no earlier agent was accepted their
price okay so for example if the prices
are all one and these probabilities are
1 over n then the ex-ante optimum is one
but the the revenue of this auction is 1
minus 1 over e and this is actually the
worst case and there's this very nice
result due to augur well at all that
says from stochastic optimization that
says that if you have a submodular
function so function this function is
mapping subsets of this set and two real
numbers if it's sub modular and you have
some distribution over subsets of those
items and the distributions have
marginals qi then if you look at the
ratio between the expected value of that
function when you sample independently
with probabilities qi compared to
sampling from this correlated
distribution that has marginals qi then
that correlation gap is as at least 1
minus 1 over e
this independent sampling always gets at
least 1 minus 1 over e of the correlated
distribution for this function so in
this case what is the what is this a
modular function it's just the max of
the over the prices in the subset so it
follows directly from this theorem that
this mechanism which which you take the
solution to the ex-ante problem you post
those prices approach them in order of
decreasing prices gives you a 1-1 over
approximation so actually this is all
much more interesting and settings
beyond single item for example if you
can serve many agents for example the
may Troi feasibility constraint and but
I'm not going to get into any of that I
just to summarize this little section on
posted prices there are many results on
posted price auctions often based on
profit inequalities they're beyond
single item I've mentioned all these
many reasons we love posted prices in
mechanism design and I guess one
takeaway is that auctions can be
approximately optimal without being
complex this is part of a kind of major
kind of drive within the field that was
sort of articulated by heartland and
roughgarden to understand the trade-offs
between simple mechanisms and optimal
mechanisms and there's been a huge line
of research to try to understand this
this work falls within that category but
of course the results all depend on
really understanding the optimal
auctions which Myerson gave us and the
other takeaway here is that the optimal
or approximately optimal auction even if
it's very complicated if you can
understand it then you get a benchmark
for evaluating more practical designs so
there's a huge ongoing quest including
by many people in this room to
understand optimal and approximately
optimal options in ever more complex
settings and I'm actually not going to
touch on that at all but it's a very
exciting line of research
so all of this everything I've discussed
so far dependent on the fact that we had
an accurate prior in our hands actually
we're also assuming independence between
agents and for some of these for the
results I presented and foremost results
we have so you can ask the question
where does this prior come from okay and
presumably it comes from previous
experience on the market so Tim was
discussing how you know in sponsored
search auctions I can use bids that
people submitted yesterday in order to
infer a prior and then you know start
doing something today it may come from
on-the-fly market analysis but you know
there are lots of questions once you do
this kind of average case analysis what
if the prior is not accurate so the
results are potentially sensitive to
small errors in the prior what if the
prior is changing over time we're seeing
different populations or whatever you
know and even if a little birdie was to
whisper in your ear exactly what the
prior was at any moment if you're
running some ongoing dynamic system you
may not want to redesign the mechanism
every time the prior changes so this
kind of raises this notion or suggests a
kind of hybrid type of analysis rather
than use the optimal auction for eeyore
something based on it for every single
setting is there some way we can come up
with an auction that's simultaneously
near optimal for lots of priors and to
mention this yesterday this was this is
the notion of prior independence so we
assume the values of the agents come
from some prior and what we want to do
is design a single not auction that has
no knowledge of the prior so that no
matter what the prior is the expected
value of the auction is within some
constant factor of the expected value of
the optimal Taylor to that prior so we'd
like this to work
no matter what the prior is in let's say
among a large class of priors so of
course you know it's not possible
without any assumptions whatsoever on
the prior but it turns out that under
relatively benign assumptions you can
actually get results like that like this
in this setting so the starting point
through an inspiration I guess for this
work as an older result by two
economists Bulow and klemperer who
showed that in a single item iid setting
regular distributions whenever that is
the expected revenue of the optimal
auction tailored to the distribution is
less than or equal to the expected
revenue of just the simple Vickrey
auction sell to the highest bidder the
second highest price as long as you add
one more bitter okay so this is a
resource augmentation type result and
kind of what it's saying is that a
little more competition is more
important than precise knowledge of the
prior okay another thing you could see
it as saying is that there's high value
from one extra sample from the
distribution or alternatively that a
random price from the distribution is
almost as good as the optimal reserve
price so you can see that if you think
about the case of N equals 1 in the case
of N equals 1 this is just post the
monopoly price it's the revenue from the
monopoly price posting and what is
victory with two agents well victory
with two agents just has each agent is
like setting a reserve price for the
other agent okay so it's like setting a
random price from the distribution for
each agent and each one of those will
contribute half the revenue which means
that the expected revenue from just
picking a random price from the
distribution of posting that for one
agent is at least half of the optimal
revenue okay and so what these guys were
able to you do
take this and really fly with it and
what their idea was they introduced this
this mechanism they called the single
sample mechanism which is you just pick
one random bitter or one random bitter
of each type if they're partitioned into
different types of distributions and use
his bid as a reserve for the others so
essentially do market research on the
fly and this mechanism gets a 22
approximation to the optimal mechanism
that's tailored to the distributions
basically no matter what the
distribution with a little asterisk okay
so this is like really cool they came up
with a beautiful new geometric argument
for for making this for getting this
result and it there are many many
extensions beyond single item again I'm
just using single items keep things
simple but the interesting cases are
well beyond that and as a beginning of a
flurry of activity on prior independent
auctions that's still ongoing okay so
once you see that one sample and is
enough to get a two approximation then
you you know it naturally raises the
question of how many samples are
necessary it sufficient to get a 1 minus
epsilon approximation to the optimal
expected revenue so basically a recent
line of research very exciting is
looking at the sample complexity
question here Allah what Ellie told us
about earlier in the week I get to see
some number of samples from the
distribution and if they're not I ID
then each one of these represents one
sample from each bidder and I run some
kind of learning algorithm that outputs
an auction and I want this auction to be
good when I run it on a new sample okay
and so basically you know the you can
take standard ideas from sample
complexity and adapt them to this
setting and do some work and you can
come up with bounds on how many samples
are necessary and efficient to get good
approximations
so some of the results are you know well
without any assumption of the
distributions you can't do anything in
the iid Sam setting you just need a
small number of samples constant number
of samples to get a woman is epsilon
approximation this results actually from
the original dang what nitai paper at
all and then people have been more
getting improvements on the number on
the sample complexity for the non iid
setting but suffice it to say that you
know it's significantly more complicated
you need to know a lot more about the
distribution in order to be able to get
a good approximation and most recently
more Morgenstern Jamie Morgenstern and
Tim have been importing ideas from
learning theory specifically the idea of
pseudo dimension which is a
generalization of VC dimension from
binary valued functions to real valued
functions and basically getting balanced
on sample complexity in terms of pseudo
dimension so the kind of cool thing is
that this pseudo dementia seems to match
our intuitive notion of what the
simplicity or complexity of a family of
auctions and you know and we'll go into
that but basically it implies good
sample complexity bound so for
distributions who support is 0 to H
essentially linear in the pseudo
dimension sample suffices so this is
part of a really interesting line of
research yeah
actually you can actually what I'm
talking about here is the setting where
you sort of imagine you first see as
some number of samples from the
distribution and then you run the
auction on a new set of n bidders okay
so obviously you know if this is
something large compared to the number
of bidders then you know you would sort
of have to do that you'd have to use
prior samples if it's very small as in
the iid setting then you can actually
sample from the people that show up
themselves and that was what was done in
those prior independent auctions so you
know this this intersection between
learning theory and mechanism design is
is gaining a lot of traction it's very
exciting and I think there's still a lot
to do one thing that I find really
interesting and complicated about this
just like as an open question is there's
an implicit assumption here that the
people providing the samples which are
other agents are not strategic okay
they're they're just providing their
samples so that later when they come
back the auctioneer can use those
samples against them you know and make a
lot of money so the question one very
it's very important for us to understand
how learning you know interacts with
strategy and I think that that there's
far from any detailed understanding on
that so I was going to say something
about prior free but I'm going to skip
that
happy to tell anyone about it later and
just I'm just going to wrap up with a
few more comments about a GT and
learning so and kind of repeat myself a
little bit so sorry so you know if you
take these ecommerce settings you know
amazon or ebay or these sponsored search
settings or uber and so on the
interactions the marketplace are very
dynamic and there's many repeated
interactions between agents okay and
these agents are uncertain about one
another they may be exhibiting learning
behavior they may be doing all kinds of
stuff but they're definitely strategic
or they may be strategic or maybe
they're myopic I don't know but they
know that information they revealed
today may be used against them tomorrow
and there's lots and lots of data that
they can take advantage of but how do
you learn from that data when that data
is provided strategically so I just want
to give you a small example just to
illustrate about how repeated
interactions are very tricky so this is
the fishmonger problem name the
fishmonger problem by almost so you have
a fishmonger every day he shows up with
a fresh fish okay and every day a buyer
wants a new fresh fish okay the same
buyer comes every day I mean we all love
our sushi right so the buyer has a value
which is let's for example drawn from a
uniform distribution on 01 but the
buyers value doesn't change from day to
day every day they have the same value
okay so every day the seller and the
buyer meet and there's another
transaction or no transaction depending
on the price the seller seller says and
the thing about this is that you know
you might ask well there's a lot there's
the potential for the seller to learn
this this agents value and you know can
he eventually start getting the full
value for
the agent every day you might think that
was the case so before I say something
about that let's just observe that in
this setting if they were only going to
meet once single buyer single seller we
know that the optimal thing to do is to
post a price and the price that you
would want to post would be one-half if
you post the price of one half then the
buyer will accept will take that price
with probability one-half if its values
above one half so the expected revenue
is going to be one quarter for a single
interaction vector action year revenue
okay now what if they're meeting for two
days so here's what again just want to
clarify the buyers value is not changing
okay you know the distribution is drawn
from up front but it's not changing so
you might think okay well i might post
the price at point five on the first day
I'm the seller if they accept that price
then I can assume that they're you know
marginal is uniform on point 5 1 if it's
uniform point 5 1 it turns out that the
optimal price this set is point 5 but if
they reject then presumably I could
assume their values uniform on 0 to 0.5
and then the optimal price to set is
point two five so if I could do this and
this is what happened then I would
actually make more than one quarter on
average per day because I'd be getting a
little extra here in the setting where
they wouldn't have bought on the first
day but this isn't what's going to
happen okay if you take a buyer with
value point six if he accepts on both
days then his utilities point 1 plus
point one is point two but if he rejects
on the first day and accepts on the
second day then his utility is point 6
minus point two five which is point 3
5's utility would be higher so this
buyer anticipating the possibility of
the price is going to go down if he
rejects you know he's waiting for the
sale is going to
um you know not do what you want him to
do okay now of course if the seller so
here in fact if the seller cook admit to
selling at the price of point five every
day then he could certainly get in
expectation one quarter every day okay
but if you can't commit it turns out
that for two days the total expected
revenue we can get is it most point four
five okay so not only can he not do any
better he will actually do worse if you
can't commit to future prices okay and
just more generally if they meet and
days in a row then without the seller's
ability to commit to future prices the
most revenue you can get from a
strategic buyer okay again it's a
strategic buyer is little o of n okay so
that's kind of interesting and it just
points to some of the complexities that
arise once you have repeated interaction
if you take strategy into account now
there's lots of ways of changing models
and understanding things in different
ways but I just think it's kind of neat
so learning there's many many questions
you know if you think about data that's
being provided to an actual learning
algorithm then how do you incentivize
providers of data to put the effort in
to give you high quality data so this is
like the crowdsourcing setting where you
want to incentivize high quality work or
how do you learn from data when the data
is both noisy and strategically
presented so for example suppose the
providers of the data actually want to
influence the outcome of the learning
algorithm so there's a huge body of work
that's emerging from various communities
not just ours on questions like this I
just point to one reference from our
community but it's it's I think there's
lots and lots of questions to answer
here and I thought I would just end by
describing one stylized question that's
been considered I think there will be a
talk about this in the
workshop the first paper I'm just going
to briefly tell you what the second
paper does so first to motivate this if
you think about an app like Waze which
recommends traffic routes for you to
take uses basically crowdsourcing to
figure out what the traffic situation is
all over the world all over the place
sorry then they they want to make good
recommendations but in order for them to
make good recommendations they need the
drivers to be exploring the space right
to some extent okay drivers may not want
to explore the space they mind won't
might want to do the thing that's best
for them or similarly a retailer like
Amazon wants users to explore products
and review them so that many products
have reviews and ultimately they can
converge to best pricings and
recommendations but they have to rely on
their users to explore the space so in
these situations ways and Amazon are
like some principle that would like to
run a proper learning algorithm to
figure out you know what the best
recommendations they can make are or
what the best products are but in order
to do that exploring is necessary on the
other hand the a user's goal in any
individuals in any particular situation
is to exploit okay so the question is
how can the principle incentivize the
users to do a sufficient amount of
exploration that the long-term learning
is as good as it can be and how good can
it be so the model that these guys
considered was a bayesian multi-armed
bandit setting exactly of the type
kamesh spoke about earlier this week you
have K arms and there are bayesian arms
so you have some sort of prior over the
reward distribution or maybe they're
markov chains like what he described and
every time an arm is pulled you can
update your prior over the rewards that
it provides and every step of user shows
up having seen all the past rewards
before they make the selection
and then they choose basically they
choose some arm and they get some reward
and the assumption here is that the user
just wants to maximize their reward
right now whereas the principal wants to
maximize the long-term reward so here
I've written it as discounted rewards
where gamma is kind of a discount factor
so they want the system to operate as
best as possible in the long run so
there's this kind of trade-off between
the user who wants to use a myopic
policy and the principle that wants to
use an optimal policy that get win this
case is the gettin's index policy that
kamesh mentioned so the way they
approach this question in this paper is
they introduce the notion of incentive
payments so at each time a bonus has
announced for each arm and now the bonus
is the assumption is that the user will
choose the arm that maximizes their
bonus plus the expected reward they get
from that arm and what they do in the
paper and I'm not going to say anything
about it is they really precisely
characterize a trade-off between the
incentive payments and the opportunity
cost so if you're willing to pay lots of
money then you can get them to implement
the optimal policy the gettin's index
but on the other hand if you're you know
that costs you a lot if you're not
willing to spend the money on incentive
payments then you know you're going to
lose a lot in the rewards relative to
the optimal policy and the question is
how what is that trade-off and that's
what they answer so I'm going to wrap up
with just saying lots of things I didn't
discuss I didn't discuss modeling of
agents for example value distributions
that aren't independent I didn't discuss
mechanism design in more complex
settings which is really all the rage
and you know people like hi and Matt and
others have been doing lots of great
work and yang there's lots of great work
in that setting
and I didn't discuss complexity of
equilibria so they're all these great
results by people like Christo's and
others you know showing that things like
Nash equilibrium are hard is there any
opportunity or what is the opportunity
here to go beyond worst case and there
along the lines of what Tim was
discussing yesterday and there are some
results of that type but I'm sure
there's much more to be done and then as
I said dynamic mechanism design is is a
very exciting topic and I I just refer
back to that list of applications that I
had on one of the earliest slides and
say that you know we're not doing enough
to actually impact those applications
perhaps for those that care about that
but maybe we don't care how to him so if
you want to know more i recommend jason
hardlines book and tim roth gardens
lecture notes and all the videos from
the semester last year on economics and
computation and thank you
yes another photo showed with a if I
think it was a given distribution that
if you can choose the order of the
players than you'll ever get 1 minus 1
over e what if you cannot choose you can
get a factor too that was the basic
posted pricing de suite so that's what
that order buys you there
the second capacitance as I recall
correctly yeah not where's the right
what's mass much yeah well there we can
just do it yeah PCG
okay oh I have the results of like
feldman at all that I mentioned there
they can also do it by sampling and get
yeah and then they I don't know that
they have results related to the sample
complexity there Clarence is very good